hey everyone the 2018 Oscars are on
Sunday and we're here with our final
predictions for all the big awards who
will win should win after the Best
Picture is announced will moonlight
somehow win again we'll get to our
predictions but first welcome to new
rock stars news deep dive into all the
biggest stories this week so we're also
gonna talk about Avengers infinity war
some dark rumors about the DC cinematic
world the new record Ralph's sequel
trailer and more I'm Erik Bosse and
joining me at the table here today are
i'm tommy Bechtold and yes i've gained
weight say anything okay all right blues
a very fetching color on you I'm Melina
yes I've gained weight and mod you don't
have to make any comment about your
weight don't play that game yeah all
right well look the guys I'm Erik Voss
I'm constantly gaining weight yeah for
depths of those seven grams will finally
be taken off my 21 grams okay let's get
started with our top story today guys
the Academy Awards on Sunday of the many
know-it-alls ranting about movies on
YouTube I would venture to say that we
here at new rockstars might be among the
most thoughtful or obsessive the line is
very thin good tweeting those two things
so before we tune in to the Oscars let's
give our final predictions of what
movies we think will take home the big
awards and guys let's start with the top
two categories Best Picture and Best
Director there are nine movies nominated
for Best Picture call me by your name
the darkest hour
we're just darkest hour Dunkirk get out
Lady Bird phantom thread the post the
shape of water in three billboards
outside Abbey Missouri and of those nine
five of them are nominated for Best
Director
Christopher Nolan for Dunkirk Jordan
Peele for get out Greta Gerwig for
ladybird Paul Thomas Anderson for the
Phantom thread and given Otoro for his
shape of water oftentimes the movie that
wins for Best Director also wants her
Best Picture but in recent years Academy
voters have somehow concluded that the
best directed movie isn't necessarily
the best movie we've talked a lot about
many of these movies on this channel but
I'm curious to know from you guys which
of these films
do you predict will win Best Picture and
director and which do you think should
win Best Picture and director will win
just saying on Best Director for a
second because it's alright del Toro is
gonna win that yeah it's it's have you
noticed it's one of those things or it's
like it's his time legacy yeah I would
want Greta Gerwig to him I just think
like she's amazing and if she won more
movies like Lady Bird and the movies
that Greta Gerwig makes would get made
so I'd be cool Best Picture
yeah I'll give it the shape of water too
even though I don't want it to I'd say
Dunkirk is a very interesting picture
which sometimes works really well with
people with voters Tom's giving me the
eyebrows which is my sign to wrap it up
Dunkirk was the most popular on YouTube
which has predicted things before but
who knows about trends does right now
only Mexicans win Best Director actually
so ah maybe that's that's more important
okay well I think it's gonna be I think
it's going to be a shape of water clean
sweep I want it to be a Dunkirk clean
sweep that was my favorite movie that I
saw I thought it was also just directing
why I seem like such a difficult movie
to direct yeah a consistent timelines
yeah consistent like the way that it
just slowly evolves like I mean you can
kind of figure it out at the beginning
that that's the the setup but then the
way that they start to weave together
I just really and also the movie just
made me anxious the whole time like
ticking phone that's my eye my piece
there solid lines be using different
speeds of a story but in a larger piece
knowing how to place them in order to
attention yeah it's a true toss-up this
year I don't know I feel like in past
years it's come down to like a couple
films like I could see any of these nine
for the most part going home with it a
director seems like a pretty clear lock
I mean for the Directors Guild Awards
Guillermo del Toro did take home and the
producers guild a shape of water one so
those tend to be pretty strong
indicators at least for director because
it's a smaller pool of people who are
voting on that category of her picture
they have a ton of different people who
like any past winner I think gets to be
an academy voter anyone who is listed as
a producer on a past winner and that's
it's a huge group of people are voting
and they turn you before was something
like only the people that had one could
vote but it was and it was like 99%
white yeah I think since they have taken
some efforts in recent years to
diversify the voting pool for Best
Picture I'm hoping that my pick for Best
Director and picture get out will take
at home Jordan Peele I think it's great
I think he he's still kind of a rookie I
think in many directors eyes so maybe
they'll kind of wait to see what what he
does for his next couple pictures before
giving him the win but I think for
picture Ike I could see it taking home
it is it's a very relevant it's a very
socially conscious movie it's very well
manufactured film and it it breaks a lot
of molds in terms of what genre QA and
Jordan posted I successfully wrote a
movie where a black guy kills a white
rich family and the audience is
applauding such a good what a reason
though that I would say that I think
he's not gonna win Best Director even
though it's a picture the second place
is really cool you know it's not that
outside of what other directors could
come up with but yeah that screenplay
the fact that it makes us feel every
emotion yeah and also I mean I wrote
something with him to where he was
talking about he literally did 400
drafts of that scream 400 drafts of
anything yeah so I think you're gonna
give him Best Screenplay that's my guess
even though it he'd be great but he's
got a long career yes yeah a lot of
great themes in that maybe as well I
mean the thing that
saved Daniels character was he was
picking cotton and the reason why a deer
motif yeah harm a reason I saw this one
twice well you lived a real life with
puzzles and games as a boy that's the
reason my family doesn't talk to me the
live ones the dead ones do though they
still got to weird
and they made into cocoa right that's a
[ __ ] end of story everyone watched my
games became part of cocoa yeah cocoa
best animated Baldwin picture okay
shaver water I think it's gonna clean up
as well a Best Picture Best Director but
I want Christopher Nolan to win I think
yes
earned it he's really done the legwork
and it's his time but I want coming by
your name to win best movie yes film
really I loved that movie it just got me
in the field I thought it was so relaxed
and well done I actually think it was a
lot better than Lady Bird and I loved
Lady Bird I just think it was much
better put together it was visually
stunning it just tight tied it all
together a lot better and then took
risks instead of you know a teenage girl
fighting with her mom ha I lived that
you know and I kind of related with that
but I think if it seems that the Academy
is pushing the envelope a little bit
more pun intended than before especially
since you know we haven't really seen
much from James Franco and he's maybe
disaster artist it's not really there he
is
so I think call me by your name it's
time do you have a beautiful gay love
story well yeah I think it'll wait and
my guess is it would take adapted
screenplay
yeah away from Logan unfortunately but
you know it sucks when they put a mic in
competition
but yeah I know I do think they're gonna
acknowledge it I actually though wonder
if for the same reasons if it's like you
know we got a pic as a voter what
political movement am I going on right a
gay love story I the the get out story
or and that's why I think yeah I think
three billboards might have a better
chance to win Best Picture it did win
for the SAG Awards right yeah and I
think that is kind of a movie that might
be if you think what the a political
movement might be the dominant one at
this year what's the his mystical
movement yeah yeah yeah I think it's
definitely bringing the coal industry
back yeah so is there any is there any
coal through the escape clause Santa
Clause three the escape clause is my new
pick her best picture ever well so those
are kind of our pet let us know what
your picks would be what you think
should and will win and in the comments
below but for now let's move on to the
acting categories we've already talked
about some of these here for Best Actor
the nominees are Timothy Shiloh May for
called me by your name Daniel day-lewis
for phantom thread his final role he
announced he's retiring
Daniel Kalu you forget out Gary Oldman
for darkest hour in Denzel Washington
for Roman Jay Israel Esquire okay for
Best Actress there's Sally Hawkins for
the shape of water Frances McDorman for
three boards outside of a Missouri
Margot Robbie for I Tanya Saoirse Ronan
for Lady Bird and Meryl Streep for the
post I know I'm listing here we're
almost done for a Best Supporting Actor
there's William Dafoe or Willem Dafoe
for the Florida Project Woody Harrelson
for three billboards Richard Jenkins for
the shape water Christopher Plummer for
all the money in the world and Sam
Rockwell for three billboards and then
for Best Supporting Actress there's mary
j blige from mud bound allison janney
for AI Tanya Lesley Manville for random
thread Laurie Metcalf for Lady Bird and
Octavia Spencer for the shape of water
so what are your guys's picks for what
you think will win and what do you think
should win for these categories we list
them straight for two minutes yeah
but I'll only make it now I know
somebody let's go yeah Maude sweet
alrighty
for best actor who will win Gary Oldman
won everything
well underwent a huge transformation for
this role I feel like we've done Winston
Churchill to death personally I mean if
you've seen the ground get dominated
with gold yeah
it's it I think I agree on Oldman he
seems to be another one he's like legacy
wins right there really went giving him
the trophy for his body of work and do
you see that name on a list like how is
he not won an Oscar before I don't know
this is his best one role that he played
Gary Oldman who should win Best Actor
Daniel Kalia he's great I thought he was
so amazing he actually picked up at the
BAFTAs the Best Newcomer and that's a
voted yeah and I know I wish he had
sympathies generally I think would be
amazing in that category because he's
only 21 years old and I think he's the
youngest guy in about 60 years or 63
years to be nominated for Best Actor so
that's a huge feat in itself but you put
him up next to Gary Oldman you're like
come on yeah it's not really comparable
the best actresses often kind of have
like a surprisingly young girl they've
got to grow into this yeah and then
little girls if they play creepy it's
like done it's so easy to just play yeah
Daniel Scalia is it said something that
like the most memorable image from get
out is just like his face was crying as
he's like in this trap state he's his
faces are so expressive you know that
role really took it out of him because
he went to a dark place to do that and
it was shot after shot and he's just
like guys like the sadness is
really in me yeah yeah he really got to
him mm-hmm so much about that movie
works and like it's still interesting
that if he's not replaceable in that
role like I can't imagine that movie
working as well with anyone else in that
part I mean he would be one of my picks
for should win I agree that Oldman
probably will win I also think I mean
I'm always just a big fan of d-day you
know like did a Louis like I think it
was great a phantom threat and he did so
much in this role that he hasn't done
before there's not like he isn't showed
[Laughter]
[Music]
you can't retire and then come back for
the role like I don't know apparently he
was like oh I'm going to retire to
become a fashion person he's a share of
the Johnny Farnham thing is it's like
that for me commit summer camp goes to
yeah so that's why it rules it up for me
I don't like that commit commit clear
enough I think well I agree I think that
all the indications point to Gary Oldman
winning but I do think like and to go
back to the other things that we
previously discussed
we were like ruling out the weird like
Oscar just doing a full reverse course
and this phantom threading everything
and being like give it to get with a
queen sweep yeah like we're gonna get
cuz it came in so late in the game to
like it like even screening wise came in
so late in the game like it knocked it
bumped a bunch of other people out that
had been nominated for Golden Globes
completely out of the categories so the
least political of them to it's the
easiest like you really couldn't argue
it I guess like but you it would be
frustrating for me and I think I'm
gauging from over every all of us here
would be most frustrated by it but I
wouldn't be surprised unfortunately but
I think yeah I think it'll probably go
to Rome and Jay is real ya know I saw it
I saw from the trailer and I have to
admit I did not see that movie and I was
like oh this should just be called going
it was like when Hilary Swank did the
Amelia Earhart movie I was like they
should just call this like going for the
Oscar she's clearly going for the Oscar
going for an Oscar this week I mean when
we look at best we liked in the
Washington Tommy
I like the Denzel Washington but Denzel
Washington State not the city a lot of
people get them confused for Best
Actress the consensus seems to be going
around Frances McDormand who really did
carry three billboards it's such like a
huge role for her and she does kind of
like loom larger than the movie itself
in a lot of ways and she's such a great
actress she's been in so many great
films so she's definitely earned it and
yeah I don't see a Fargo two pointer
really isn't it yeah in a way instead of
being the police she's challenging
police yes yes she wears it and she's
already I think one for one of the ones
leading up to it whether it be a SAG her
critics
[Laughter]
yeah but she's quite political as well
so in Lewis the conversation about who's
gonna make a stand she's gonna get up
there and use her speech to kick some
ass I feel yeah I really think the
female roles this year were in my
opinion more interesting including the
Best Supporting Actress which I think
out I'm kind of torn between Laurie
Metcalf from Lady Bird and Allison
Janney fries yeah Jani is just so great
and like I love her and everything that
she's in school than me do you know how
few women are taller than me yeah
there's about set yes yeah that's what I
would totally I think you'd toaster yeah
I don't know yep and looking at I played
basketball before and I just give the
other opponent the Bulbul yeah me down
technically Meyer yeah yeah I'm a nice
person all it is so you're going Franny
Mac yeah your mom Annie Annie Mac is
that printer Oh like a Nickelodeon show
the
is even funny men do that to get the
award yeah yeah I think we don't with
actress and any other best actress she's
not getting it and then also Margot
Robbie did a great job Margot Robbie
came at movie was bonkers saying Margot
Robbie's gonna win one yeah at some
point I think yes absolutely
our Suicide Squad - yeah Harlem City
kind of the standout especially playing
against type no yeah yeah and the the
Best Supporting Actor category it seems
to be the the big supporting parts from
three billboards seem to be dominated
between Woody Harrelson and Sam Rockwell
for these parts yeah I mean my I think
Sam Rockwell tends to be the one like
people are still kind of getting used to
the fact that Woody Harrelson's taking
on some more serious roles so but Sam
Rockwell has been playing eleven
interesting roles over the course of his
career he seems to be the favorite I
would say probably should win and I
don't know my opinion would win it's a
very difficult role for him to play not
a very likeable person I mean again
you've got Christopher Plummer who came
in and rescued and saved a movie from
the Kevin Spacey saga and he shot it in
what seven night ten days exactly
someone pointed out to me that if
Christopher Plummer wins it destroys
everything everyone's ever said about
the craft of acting yeah yeah it's like
you just like shows up and like what are
the lines for best actor and then also
Christopher there's basically saying
none of this really matters how you do
this yeah just feed me he's like that
whole everyday hero just like line Louis
consistent character for every one day
I'll find it
let's move on now to talk about some
movies that came out this year that
maybe didn't have the luck to get an
Oscar nomination that we thought were
really good maybe just the politics of
the nominating process went against them
sure right off that I have to
say that how is Blade Runner 2049 not
all over yeah these nominations that
movie is not even a movie it's like
transcendent it's on another level
that's how I thought about interstellar
it's like the last time I said that
where it's like you're not just watching
a film and this doesn't even study like
so much is happening in this blade over
20 49 checks off everything I could
think of what would make a Best Picture
and it drove me nuts that it wasn't on
there I also throw out there really
quick data Ingrid goes west actually
it's actually a really like it it's get
out like a little bit the weights it
makes me feel and Aubrey Plaza honestly
like if she was gonna be now and it like
I feel like it could be for a character
like that not like her safety not
guaranteed yeah character were more one
where she just goes out there and really
plays hard but yeah both those movies
are really great you should check them
out it's great especially if you are an
Instagram celebrity and want to be
terrified for your life yeah I guess I
won't watch it I feel bad for baby
driver it's the Kevin Spacey syndrome
again where it's a great movie there's
great acting in it the editing and the
music the soundtrack combined really
really well done Edgar Wright it's an
amazing director but of course you can't
touch you can't go near it
Kevin Spacey speakers on it already seem
to be the two most punished movies
because have one person's misdeeds Jon
Hamm because I barely remember Kevin
Spacey on this way like as part of that
movie that the movie is so much more
than Kevin Spacey yeah yeah and if you
think like a movie like all the money in
the world might have actually benefited
for because I don't know if Christopher
Plummer would have been nominated if not
this narrative behind the movie
propelling them into that role I think
that's often the case we look at movies
like baby driver and even like Blade
Runner 2049 that narrative and the story
of the movie end up becoming what gets
it into these categories and these
nominations not so much like the content
of the movie itself Michelle Williams
should have gotten at least a nod sure
she did such an amazing job twice yeah
we
that movie so I think that that's a real
shame that that's like the whole scandal
over it really kind of put her
performance in the shadows a little yeah
unfortunately she's she's great she
feels like one of the most punished
actresses
out there like she just like could never
win it even in her roles even on
Dawson's Creek she was like the most it
was like should have done something
yeah I was surprised with how you know
as a non horror fan myself not even not
a horror fan a person who's too afraid
to watch horror movies I thought that
hit hit it was so universally beloved by
horror fans and was considered this
masterpiece I was shocked that it didn't
get any recognition at all although I
guess maybe it's a hard movie to
nominate because there's it's such an
ensemble performance so you can't really
give out individual nominations and then
though the kids in that movie like not
all of them but most of them are really
good yeah yeah it's one that's they like
horror in addition to like sci-fi and
superhero movies tends to be
unappreciated
yes feels like some people were like
tricked into like they're like well
maybe it's more of just a thriller yeah
and then we can nominate it and then
well let us know down below what your
snubs and your eyes are we're from these
nominations and what movies that you
think will win on Sunday what do you
think should win and what movies that
you think we should all go out and see
even if they aren't really part of this
whole Oscar campaign world yeah and and
and we'll see what happens on Sunday
hopefully our ballots will end up doing
well if you're into that whole thing but
before we move on to our trivia question
this week I wanted to quickly update you
guys on some big news I dropped this
week Avengers infinity war will be
released a week earlier than planned in
the u.s. moving up from May 4th to April
27th for my dad's birthday
Avengers man do you like super super
hunk
he loves hogs this is an ounce on a
jokey Twitter exchange between Robert
Downey jr. and Marvel Studios accounts
the movie will now premiere in America
at the same time it does around the
world and it gives Marvel an agressive
head start to the summer movie season
gives us a chance to avoid those spoiler
tweets from our friends in Pakistan
please stop doing that to us guys we
watch movies a week after you do oh we
don't have the answers to your questions
but giving Sam our friend a little less
time to get through his MCU re-watch
that looks what I mean but it's daebak
right what are you doing so this makes
sense yeah I don't want to compete well
let's move on to this week's trivia
question okay so we're it's an Oscar
themed trivia question you know you're
yeah the Grouch or office yeah okay so
here we go of all the DC or marvel
superheroes to appear in oscar-nominated
films Batman has appeared in the most
six movies which superhero has appeared
in the second most oscar-nominated films
so I think we're looking not at
nominations number of films that
achieved Oscar nominations after Batman
who has appeared in six movies that have
had that accolade which superhero has
appeared in the second most number of
films I have no idea what this actual
hero for the name of the superhero
superhero who has on the side and so
there have been six Batman movies to get
Oscar nominations okay okay what other
let's think of all the other superheroes
we know that would be appeared in movies
they've been for example several x-men
movies name a superhero who has appeared
after Batman in the second most number
of films that have gotten Oscar
nominations for those movies
acting on the side got it yeah I think
you're the only person who is confused
by that Tommy's just ready to the name
again great so we're all writing our
answers right now write your answer down
below in the comments and don't skip
ahead to the end of the video
wait you know and see if you if you're
right don't look at us Suicide Squad got
nominated Suicide Squad diggit nominee
that was one of the six Batman movies
that was he did up here in okay well
later so we'll review the answer to our
trivia question the closest as decided
by our judges will do our sign up
goodbyes at the end of video if multiple
people get it right well we'll figure
that out when we get there and then the
winner will get to do our sign up
goodbyes whatever dumb new character
they're trying out meanwhile the loser
will have to cleverly riff on in other
news the winner doesn't have to do a new
character Eric's version of winning is
he gets to do a new character right
which you do whatever you want
what reward could be better just
Erickson voices Wow maybe he's just a
little shy and either way the question
all questions are only declarative
statements are on it's gonna be like
Johnny Five okay well speaking of Batman
let's move on to another potential big
story that dropped this week some rumors
about some very bad news that is about
to break
concerning Warner Brothers in the DC
cinematic world they can't take it this
week John can't be a cryptically
announced on his open mic podcast that
he is a hundred percent certain over
some upcoming bad news regarding the DCU
that what caused the fans to lose their
minds and it could come out in the next
month or he said next six months we'll
see why don't like that there but this
has caused some wild speculation
surprise surprise and yeah Ben a
suspicion that Johnny boy just likes
indulging that hot hot Goss as much as
the rest of us do
similar speculum what this is now in the
past similar scoops of his included the
the rumors about Ben Affleck possibly
leaving and that Jake Gyllenhaal might
take over the character of Batman so
people are assuming that this isn't what
the thing he's been teasing so guys
let's dish let's do some bas guys here
who think the work what do you think the
worst possible news for fans of the DC
movies would be to hear right now I want
to talk about the credibility of the
people making these lander statements
because usually in the comic book
usually in in the hero superhero space
when it comes to movies it's umberto
Gonzalez I think his name is who is he
heroic Hollywood he has for the last
decade bidden building up sources and so
I usually believe what he has to say a
little bit more John Campea has worked
for I think AMC and in Collider for
about half a decade and so I'm not
entirely sure who his sources are and
it's a little bit of a broad thing to
say that I'm a hundred percent certain
that something's gonna happen under
percent certain of anything then they
went and someone took that soundbite and
I think it was the rap and said that he
said that Matt Reeves was leaving the
band and then he had are you going up
and down but then so yes so the rapper
wrote an article I think that was over
Collider no that was his own company
anyway regardless they quoted him out of
context saying that Matt Reeves was
leaving the Batman for sure so then he
had to go back and say that's not what I
said and kind of even admit not admit
but just say like it was just I'm just
making a statement something Bad's gonna
happen which feels like whenever there's
a movie that takes place in medieval
times and there's like a town witch and
the witch really feels like a bad for
like your family is cursed right before
they burn her the Sun falls off the
horse
John Campea is a witch and and Matt
Reeves did say on Twitter people said
say it ain't so any responded saying it
ain't so like so that's clearly not what
he would be discussing I don't even know
what else who did bad news obviously but
if Jake Gyllenhaal that is not the worst
thing ever that it's not a bombshell
it's pretty much what we were kind of
waiting maybe wait forever it's just
gonna be shelved or is it like something
you guys know the directors of that are
the directors of game night yes yeah the
guys who did they brought spider-man
homecoming right super funny idea yeah
we'll see I mean I don't really know
I think there's it's really easy just to
trigger these DC fanboys out there with
any kind of bad news that are happening
cuz they're so quick to just assume
Warner Brothers is gonna ruin their
favorite characters I think it's easy to
kind of indulge in like bad things are
on the horizon guys easy prediction as
well something is bad happening with DC
movies which is the narrative it's been
the narrative and it was well let's move
on to some brighter news from the DC
cinematic world another update from this
week guys leaked step photos of what
looks like Zachary Levi and costume on
the set of Shazam let's take a look here
Oh looks like the movie will not be
holding back this bright red and yellow
a right red and gold color scheme on in
the comics colors that bright jingle all
the way over here
look at their big another sequel to that
that's not Larry the Cable Guy guys I
I'm just happy to see it I mean
Levi has compared the tone of this movie
to something close to the guardians of
the galaxy with or ragnerok thoughtfully
that light-hearted colorful tone will
perk things up over on the DC side yeah
he looks like guest on from being the
base man what about those boots in the
question it's it's good I've been
desperate to have a superhero role for a
very long time I gotta wonder is this
maybe the kind of scene where it's like
just kidding that's not gonna be and
also like a little bit of trivia I got
from John Campea those boots were
actually made by Daniel day-lewis his
character and the Phantom threat but
another thing to look forward to in this
movie that I keep forgetting thin wool
part Mike from stranger things and
Richie from it will be playing the young
Billy Batson all right well let's move
on to another game caller if you're
watching uh another big story from this
week wreck-it Ralph - also known as
Ralph breaks the internet has a new
trailer released by Disney this week
showing Ralph and vanellope 's new
adventures as they surf the worldwide
web we're going through tubes this
trailer is full of little Easter eggs
and references that are pretty great
let's break down this trailer and point
out all these missable details we're
gonna run through quickly here we go
okay first this shot of lit wax arcade
tells us that the second movie takes
place six years after the first the sign
says happy 11th birthday Susie Susie
with a V o which is a callback to the
sign in the first movie when it said
happy 5th birthday Susie Susie with the
Venus
really love this arcade she comes here
every year all right also once we go
inside of the arcade there's a bunch of
details the arcade games include pac-man
Space Invaders Virtua cop also the made
for the movie ones sugar rush and fix-it
Felix jr. that wreck Ralph is in simpler
better times right the box for this
guy's new Wi-Fi router says 800 or 8000
percent faster ish and the router sits
atop a Dragonslayer video game that was
in stranger things season 2 if remember
yeah now inside inside Litwack office
you can see collectable yoda and
Chewbacca plates and this computer looks
like that 90s era iMac with the you know
remember with the color body and the USB
Wi-Fi adapter and on the desktop for
that computer one of the file says
letter to Nana which is a callback to
the first movie when Litwack made a joke
about his Nana had gone cuckoo and had
to be taken out to pasture inside the
Internet our ton of Easter eggs
referencing different websites just to
list the ones we spot and quickly
there's Alison e Hulu Cisco YouTube
TripAdvisor IMDB National National
Geographic eBay they're also a few
parody sites like the daily roast for
the daily beast smashable for Mashable
expect you for Expedia and Buzz food for
BuzzFeed which feels like it probably
already exists like BuzzFeed already
gotta have this tasty yeah ok there you
go
and one of the things being auctioned
off at eBay this is fun is the genies
lamp from Aladdin
notice how it's going for 35 bucks
that's a probably and out of the joke
house lamp was like considered worthless
at the beginning of Aladdin
there are also cameos from surge
protector and Qbert those were
characters in the first movie and
various internet jokes about pop-up ads
and clickbait clickbait headlines and if
you look closely the background there's
a pretty dirty joke with a help desk
providing services for unzipped services
and history clearance feel like I'd be
at that all the time
gross
and this ending bit with a pancake
milkshake game it's pretty pretty great
it's very reminiscent of the exploding
man gag and Monty Python's the meaning
of life I love it and a lot of people
have actually pointed out that the
little girl playing this game in the
back of her car on the iPad is the same
character design as baby Moana now it
could be a coincidence but this movie
was animated and written by the same
exact team that did Moana so it's
probably an intentional Easter egg game
if it screws with the continuity what do
you guys think wrecker Alf too will
succeed when it comes to internet humor
where things like maybe the emoji movie
version already play a 1 when it comes
to Easter eggs and the eighties cold
yeah and all that kind of stuff but
wreck-it Ralph was before ready play 1
so I think it's really timely did it
really well the first time the humor was
on point I believe it's the same team
that also did frozen yeah the same yes
she did the first record round and she
went on a dead frozen yeah yeah right
okay yes she's doing well she actually
did the screenplay for wrinkle in time
as well oh yeah it's a strange movie
yeah you don't like Oprah being a blonde
or what's it's too much rate yeah
well record Ralph I really did enjoy the
first one and I was amazed at how many
different like references they were able
to fit in a movie I am excited to see
this I hopefully that like some of those
internet humor things are very toned
down and they they keep it more about
like yeah it sounds like your parents
talking about yeah cuz how do you how do
you encapsulate something as like huge
as it's our entire lives now or in the
internet how it's not like something
your reference like magazines she broke
the internet by pouring champagne
that's old but like so they just very
even making a joke about a meme yeah
the title
from John Campea just let me know that
new rock stars is one of our first
hosted videos on this channel what about
Kim Kardashian breaking the internet oh
nice well maybe they'll have like a
parody of Mean Girls I would believe in
yourself odd
well let us know what you're most
excited about for Ralph breaks the
internet wreck-it Ralph to comment down
below and hit us up on Twitter and as a
reminder to subscribe to new rock stars
for more trailer breakdowns videos about
Pixar movies like The Incredibles and
Coco in a really weird one about cars
thanks everybody alright guys now it's
time to move on to our new rock stars
news lightning round
you guys tweeted us questions I'm going
to fire these questions at my co-host we
have to answer them as quickly without
hesitation as possible because I like to
throw these curve balls right alright
here we go
for mod at say oppa wants to know what
plot would you like Dan and Dave to take
on for their Star Wars movie Dan and
Dave the showrunners of Game of Thrones
who are now getting a new star series
and which Game of Thrones actors would
you bring along not not Jon Snow whoever
probably whoever died in season 1 and 2
because they didn't get a big run
so bounty hunters Jon it's dark Ned Ned
gotta have a bit of Robb Stark what's
his name I should play satine who is the
queen of the Duchess of Mandalore trust
me
Mandalorian look it up murmurs okay for
Phillip at smarta against Lee wants to
know to anyone who bothers to answer do
you think
well well I'm good I assigned it to you
do you think Loki will get his
Redemption to remain a traitor in
villain love you guys Thanks Loki your
reference seen the trailer moment that's
all we know about Infinity Ward to where
it looks like he's giving the tesseract
to Thanos so everyone is saying that
that's him
turning on everyone again oh yeah I'll
go ahead and say no that's a misdirect I
think they wouldn't put in the trailer
first of all if it was that I think that
Loki's Ark is most near completion
toward Redemption
especially after Ragnarok where he was
doing the most for fighting for the good
side I think that he had the tesseract
for the whole time he was playing odin
why didn't he give it to Thanos then I
think that Thanos hates Loki probably
there's a he he like didn't do what he
wanted and didn't they say something
he's gonna come after you or something
he's gonna die a good guy Tommy this
monster does Aquaman have a cloaca okay
couple couple things we need to break
down define that what is a cloaca Thank
You cloaca is an orifice that it's a
it's a booty hole it's a booty hole that
exists in certain animals
well kinda like yours but unlike ours
it's all wishes yes I think Aquaman
probably has all the holes that people
come with all the holes is my favorite
song and then
listen bottom line back told I guarantee
one thing to his fans and I know that
there's at least ten of you out there
Aquaman's got an out hole that Aquaman's
got a dead halt and he's got other holes
in the holes and he's got gills and he's
got thrills and he's got spills if you
like the ocean
you're gonna love Aquaman and Kevin
Spacey it was shunned from all the
awards and that's good and Christopher
Plummer is gonna win for control of
shadow government which is from United
States yeah actually there's a KOICA
definitely okay there we go Tommy wake
up Tommy till we go okay for me
agile Cramer 13 stupid would never say
that pick one and use it for the rest of
your life use caps shield as a dinner
plate use dr. Strange's Cape as a
blanket or use Thor's hammer in your
butt hammer in the butt I don't think
that was what was that I'm taking the
shield as a dinner plate man you won't
have to go back for seconds that Golden
Corral when you got your cap shield as a
dinner shadow government real quick okay
these lizards are everywhere they're
Reptoids not a thing all right well here
we go not this I made up all these names
you weren't listening for the whole in
Bates off monster and then let's answer
your question with some dignity Aquaman
does have a cloaca and he rinses it out
daily there you go how do you spell it
Chloe I see oh I see a
our parents are so proud yes all right
well let's move on thank you all of you
who tweeted us these questions tweet
next week on the air all right next up
let's take a look at what we got in the
pipeline for videos coming out on this
channel the next week guys walking dead
still going strong or strong if you
consider rating series low to be well it
got well reviewed but the ratings were
extremely low it was a step up from the
serie or the midseason finale back in
December but it's still historically the
lowest since season two ratings rise of
Walking Dead there's all kinds of
reasons why guys I actually think last
week's episode was pretty good like
narrative Lee speaking as its own
episode but the whole show is just its
way from what's great about the comics
you know and and I hope they can find I
have hope that they can rediscover
what's great about because currently
this all-out war is the best part of The
Walking Dead comics it's amazing that
all these episodes aren't freaking great
I think a good way to do it is AMC
starts shelling out the money so Jeffrey
Dean Morgan can appear in every episode
he is the best character on the show
right now why is he only in like 25
percent of the episodes makes no sense
anyway I haven't watched the show in a
few years but if they can keep the
dynamic in my group super close I think
they're that Walking Dead can never fail
it'll never fail yeah okay so yeah
episode 10 airing on Sunday you can
watch it after the Oscars and then we'll
have our breakdown of it and make sure
to tweet us whatever big questions we
had after watching the episode because
as you know we work those into our break
downs Sam isn't here but he's still
continuing to do his MCU re-watch next
week
well he'll be talking about everyone's
favorite MCU movie Thor the dark world
but he found some really interesting
details that you're definitely gonna
want to watch this vid arc world
Jurassic Park is and then we we have
some other videos coming out about one
of them we're gonna be looking at the
future of the x-men movie franchise
there's gonna be a ton of moot
apparently six movies to come out across
2019 and 2020 not even including the two
x-men movies between Deadpool 2 and Dark
Phoenix to come out this year so we're
gonna break down everything to look
forward to there they're still playing
forward even in spite of this Disney
merger Fox Studios still has a plan then
they are sticking to it so an x-men I
mean if you think like you know Marvel
in general gets convoluted like 90% of
the convoluted storylines in Marvel are
the x-men so there's so much left to do
and there's so much they could do it's
actually really exciting yeah like if
they just because you could did you ever
think if you should yeah here's what I
say about x-men the dark world drastic
part yes okay well now comes the time
for a 15-second shout out guys each of
us has a 15 seconds to shout out or a
plug or a ramble about anything that we
want Tommy well you start mod why don't
you start shout out to fallout shelter
it's an app I've been playing it for far
too long I'm currently running three
different vaults but it's cool because
my internet keeps crashing and my
packets going out in my apartment so
it's the only thing that I can do and
play all right listen 15 seconds I'll
take it from here guys I recently had
the pleasure of watching the MU or the
TV series on Netflix end of the effing
world it's super great it's only eight
episodes are all like 20 minutes long
it's very dark it's very messed up and
it just follows it's almost like a
Bonnie and Clyde type relationship with
two english teenagers and they're kind
of borderline psychopathic or
self-diagnosed psychopathic but their
relationship is very sweet and very
violent and it's kind of fun to see this
relationship unfold it's based off of
the graphic novel series and Stefan
Utley worth checking out we can get it
done in a day why not do it yeah Tommy
baseball is back and it's better than
for pitchers and catchers and all other
position players have reported to
Florida and Arizona and those guys are
currently trying their best and I tip my
cap to all the baseball players out
there for achieving a dream hold on
we're reaching the limit of everything
Eric knows about baseball one is the
Netflix query shows only H and I'm not
used to that oh I also say if you're
just bored on Netflix look up John
Mulaney and a sitcom that's gonna run
forever oh no all right let's finally
return to our trivia question that we
asked and we're gonna redistribute here
I know one wrote oh yeah okay well read
that and then Sam's answer from last
week
yeah is that did you write that oh my
boob it okay great so just to remind
ourselves of what the question is of all
the DC and Marvel superheroes to appear
in oscar-nominated films Batman has
appeared in the most six movies which
superhero has appeared in the second
most oscar-nominated films let's start
down the line I had Philip and he
guessed metal man slash Rocket Man which
I believe he meant to say Iron Man
reference to Tommy's dad
iron Ironman Ironman bottom-line
Bechtold says please help I'm being held
hostage by Eric tank vas I will only go
free if you then move Oh Tommy
my answer is Wolverine you know there's
a lot of it's a it's kind of a top-heavy
answer there Tommy maybe we should stick
to the facts
truth character that we were asked for
the character yeah
all right go ahead Philip wouldn't mind
Ericsson spider-man well our answer is
Iron Man ding-ding-ding-ding he was in
for oscar-nominated movies and the
characters of Superman spider-man
Wolverine guardians of the galaxy
characters and war machine were in two
oscar-nominated movies yeah he's always
into the iron man's about the most
movies whatever an Iron Man's in
everything yeah he's in every movie so
you think like yeah Avengers and not all
these characters are in Avengers and in
these Hulk movie swept made another
movie okay well our winner probably
Philip definitely got Iron Man yeah you
a bottom line Wolverine was a great
guess and there also seemed to be a cry
for help that when you'll be punished
later and otherwise up and then
Jack's disease where you grow at four
times the rate of a normal person well
Phillip we'll do our good-byes and we're
gonna run through some of our in other
news headlines if we did not have time
for I will read each headline Tommy will
have to make a joke at the end of each
headline to cleverly riff on it good all
right here we go in other news
guardians of the galaxy director James
Gunn tweeted that baby bert is actually
the original groots son oh I thought
that grandmother willow was groots
grandmother and that therefore
Pocahontas was groots mother and if we
do our family tree we came to that same
conclusion it's a common misconception
wig is in talks to play the villain
rumored to be cheetah of the upcoming
Wonder Woman sequel okay well I think
that that would be a great couple and
Kristen Wiig has certainly been cheated
out of some great roles lately so this
could be great for her a Wonder for her
career as a woman in Hollywood here we
go
the creators of the second frozen movie
have said that they're open to the idea
of giving Elsa a girlfriend well if they
ever want to have children I've also
frozen my sperm
[Applause]
all right next up in the novelization of
Star Wars the last Jedi the our princess
Leia's our general Leia's final words to
Chewbacca are revealed to be it's just
us now really it's not is this plane
shaking or is it just me plane
okay Fisher was on a plane when she had
a head okay and James Gunn also engaged
on Twitter with a Mark Hamill leading to
the two men planning for Hamill to have
a role in the next guardians of the
galaxy oh that's that's great - I also
support that casting Twitter seems like
a really safe way to negotiate things as
we can tell by our leaders in political
office that if two people communicate on
Twitter
good things happen no matter what I once
communicated with the man I thought was
my biological father but it turned out
to just be James Spader yes by the
assist
I also responded to that cuz speaker
said that story and I read back going
that'd be a big an overwhelmingly big
yes for me and Mark Hamill liked my win
that's so great Wow
now I know what you like when you have
kids and like that try taking away for
goodbyes our goodbyes this week in any
style I'm gonna give my co-host a
compliment so thank you for watching
this week's episode of new masters news
I want to thank our host Maude Garrett
sure she's beautiful but she actually is
so well informed so smart and so
talented and really nice off camera so
follow her at Maude Garrett OH
Tommy Bechtold well he's not allowed to
have social media he's still one of the
funniest people I know one of the nicest
guys in Los Angeles so if you want his
personal phone number oh yeah sorry
about that Carrie Fisher choking yes I
wish I could have it back yeah maybe
I'll have a heart attack instead no or
for her or with her in solidarity so if
you wanna hit him up it is 585 and then
Eric Foss he's one of the smartest
people I know the third funniest person
I know why but he's so good on this
channel isn't he follow him at EA Voss
and anywhere he goes to do news shows
improv yeah and follow me on my new
podcast Sam Sam Sam
yeah it's great okay yeah all right well
comment down below and tweet us at new
rock stars like this video share it
around subscribe to me rock stars or
deep dives and all the stuff you love
see you guys next week bye I love to use
would be very Mike I love you very much
yeah